starting a garden big polar Brooke Lemar
Tech University Miami Heat
[Applause]
flying started before that awful foot
injury let's get back into routines Oh
get more minutes as Kelly gets a nice
finish from weight but getting back to
cover
levert his 35th game of the year and his
21st start for Brooklyn can't leave the
ball right there with three points
laid up to baptistry - lieutenant
six points here in the first quarter for
Haslam
13 unanswered points for Brooklyn under
a missed left in the first boom it's
waiting for the corner
13 seconds left of the cool wave to the
cutting Olynyk
right to the last bounce five left in
the first half wage last game of his
career shoots the jumper on Shiva has it
very plain wait the night has played 15
minutes has 8 points 5 boards four
assists
make it 5 assists
for the fly Duncan Robinson skiers Twain
pretend you Donna you did it again 8
points for islem three-point like that
great arc on that shot nice
follow-through get really coming into
his own here in Brooklyn Lurie's but
able to lead much more mature player
since leaving
Wade locates the defensive measures this
move right here change of pace has the
big Allen on him gorgeous spin and then
get into that reverse left hand and I
the just reward is blank your last two
games alongside your brother team 21 but
Duncan Robinson with 10 points on the
bench
20-point lead for Brooklyn two minutes
left of the third Duncan Robinson who
was left for the jumper it's good Duncan
Robinson another three for him senior
2014 we're in a sister well
[Applause]
here we're gonna see the quick burst and
then the driving kick and that's gonna
get up the triple double up with the
assistant it's beauty of all people that
look at his friends right there join it
LeBron Chris Paul Carmelo to the chili
finest weekly play at the Nassau County
Coliseum on Long Island the G League
jets fight again 22-250 to the countdown
has moved inside of three minutes
there's Wade up three
a parting gift travel mistletoe
the last seconds of Dwyane Wade's career
[Applause]
thank you doesn't seem strong enough how
about we love you we'll never forget you
[Applause]
[Music]
his basketball career is over let the
rest of his life begin with all the
peace joy and happiness one man and one
family can
[Applause]
but on the basketball cats bless Miami
and deep nation with a great Dwayne Wade
so humble so grateful so thankful
it's open seas it's over Dwyane Wade's
careers over ends with a triple
[Music]
hard to imagine the emotion inside
Dwayne Wayne right now what he's
thinking what he's feeling they'll hear
from him after the game matter of fact
we're gonna hear from him is just
seconds from now how about you Donna's
hassle tonight 30 minutes and a
double-double with 12 points and 11
rebounds you think he'll remember
forever that he made the shot that game
Dwayne Wade a triple-double in his final
game and he'll be holding that over him
for three dinners and drinks forever I
don't know what's harder to believe that
he ended with a 30 point game and a
triple-double where the fact that his
career is open now the last Jersey
exchange of the season and the career
Fort Wayne Wade his good friend his
draft class partner Carmelo Anthony
that hug has me
now that brought us to championship
those two along with Chris Bosh and
their teammates the Heat were NBA Kings
in 2012 and 2013 and Twain gave us our
first championship back in O six when he
had won a great championship series for
an individual player in a history of the
league average 35 points a game of a
series and nearly 40 points per game
Emma heats four wins to secure their
first-ever NBA title
these dedicated managers easing up their
backs to nothing thank you awesome
picture taking place with all the heat
teammates behind the man look at the
Brooklyn hats they're gone through the
road jerseys changed but the moment is
doing event
[Applause]
LeBron James Chris Paul and Carmelo
side-by-side with a good friend Dwyane
Wade
the heat lose the game 1:13